hi i'm charlie barnett i play allen's
devery hi i'm chloe stephanie i play
nora hi i'm greta lee and i play maxine
hi i'm natasha leon and i play nadia on
russian doll and we're here to play
who's who for
buzzfeed question number one who is most
likely to start laughing and break
character during a take
natasha chloe chloe
that's what it sounds like too number
two who is the best at doing impressions
of other cast members natasha natasha
yeah
natasha but they all end up being
natasha too i mean like it's fun it's
through the wormhole of natasha charlie
is like i know that's the thing
that was happening to me this weekend
greta is you think so seriously you want
me to do that buddy buddy i'll be here
for you chloe's always always like ah
all right guys so are we gonna do this
or not i don't think that mark is gonna
work well let's try it but he's like i'm
the most likely to turn into the a.d
number three who's most likely to turn
into their russian doll character tasha
i say charlie charlie's most likely to
keep the mustache around so that is
alan i love this mustache now it is it
is staying as far as it can go who is
the least like the russian doll
character chloe
she's not a nut job you see
who is the most likely to find
themselves caught in a continuous time
loop uh oatmeal the cat oatmeal okay um
it's like you get caught taking a selfie
charlie rebecca henderson
refute the hell out of that greta i
never take that i don't even take photos
you're most likely to steal something
from set i say myself because i actually
definitely mean
all right
i still chew things chloe i steal
something from every set i'm ever on at
least steal like 10 pairs of underwear
and some socks
are you the only one who's not stealing
because i'm stealing a ton of stuff
that's so [ __ ] lame i'm the only one
who's definitely not stealing i saw
something from the belly what did you
see oh you stole the sunglasses little
baby sunglasses that were like pink
period though and i was like they
probably rented these ain't nobody else
you know it's doubly messed up because
you said you wanted them so i put
another pair in my pocket at the end of
the day and they're in my closet
and they should be volumes and i have
all of maxine's rugs i have like tons of
magazine stuff
yeah i know mexicans but i would rate
the [ __ ] out of that place who's most
likely to randomly burst into a song on
set natasha
i do a lot of singing on set i guess who
is most likely to give the best
relationship advice i think maybe greta
well natasha's thing she's always like
and greta over here she's like normal
like she like loves her husband what's
up with that
who's most likely to nail a scene on the
first take
it's either greta or chloe like charlie
i feel like we're both a little more
like exploratory yeah we're all over we
shoot yeah i feel like chloe and i are
trying to be time efficient for you yeah
we've come from like an indie world
where we're like oh we can't do we're
not going to be able to do this again we
got to get it right we lost charlie
charlie's on a boat this is what
happened charlie's
most likely to bail on a junket because
he's got to go sailing man
who's most likely to get caught taking a
nap on set i feel like it was me i was
most likely to take a nap especially in
budapest because i was so [ __ ]
jet-lagged i'm not a method actor but
all that stuff we had to do where we
were so tired and we just landed and i
was like pissed because it's the middle
i mean
it's not not what was actually happening
i can't nap so i know i'm not the number
i know natasha is very good at power
napping at lunch time
not so much anymore it's getting older
honey i'm good at like sleeping
[Music]
who's most likely to throw a party after
work i'm all over there i never want to
leave the house if i'm home and i never
want to go home once i'm out so i'm like
we've been shooting all day we're
exhausted but we're already out of the
house let's keep it going we already
have makeup on
yeah like i already got my makeup on
thank you buzzfeed thanks buzzfeed
thanks so much and make sure you guys
catch russian doll on netflix
[Music]
you